As we go to our next game,
There's Waldo.
Back in the 20th century
our "find the panda" meme
was an anorexic world traveler
with a bum knee
who dressed like a gay
French merchant marine
named Waldo.
Uh, we looked everywhere
for this (bleep) guy.
And I'm happy to report
the Internet has found him
many times over.
So I'm gonna show you some
photos of some Waldos,
and you have to tell me
where the hell
they just were, all right?
First up, this bosomy Waldo.
Jamie.
Uh, writing poetry that
the world isn't ready for.
All right, points.
Next one, where-where
was this guy, Doug?
Looks like he just got dumped
out of Santa's bag.
Points.
Next up, uh, where
were these two, Jamie?
Uh, Christmas
at Robert Durst's house.
Aw.
Points to Jamie Lee.
Uh, next, next, what about, uh,
what about man's best Waldo?
Chris.
Licking all that peanut butter
off your mom's pussy!
HARDWICK:
Oh, Waldo!
I like that in that scenario
he puts on that disguise
to lick her pussy.
HARDWICK:
Yeah.
Well, those are
my dad's glasses, so...
Straight up.
And lastly, these beardo Waldos.
Yes, Jamie.
Uh, just Brooklyn.
That...
HARDWICK:
Points. Yes, for sure.
-Can I address one thing
real quick? -Yeah.
The dude on the right
is definitely
giving the dude on the left
a hand job, right?
-That's absolutely... -HARDWICK:
Yeah, oh, there's no...
yeah, there's no question.